you want to go in to see what
my clothes sure the world might feel
heavy and dark but guys have no fear
because kylie jenner's daughter stormy
webster is here to lift your spirits
with a whole lot of poolside cuteness
no no no i know what you're doing
just your feet i know where this is
gonna go on sunday the 23 year old
beauty mogul hit up her insta story to
share this clip with stormy at the
reality star's 36.5
million dollar la mansion dipping her
toe in the pool
you want to get in the pool with your
clothes on yeah
she does this every day let me just put
my feet in
yeah well what started off as the
two-year-old's toe
quickly turned into a full-blown fully
clothed
swim sesh and you know what kylie was
here for it
and she got in too pj's included in my
clothes mommy
okay i'll get in with my clothes okay
i'm
in here but like
is anyone else mad impressed with
stormy's swimming skills
like she did a somersault people
oh she fully swims does it get any cuter
than that
apparently it does cue the oz people
because on sunday the toddler's famous
dad travis scott
posted this pic to his insta story yeah
those are daddy daughter matching nikes
the rapper also shared this pick of
stormy hanging out with him and his pals
of course rocking their matching kicks
back in august the 29 year old rapper
shared that video of his little girl
accompanied by this shot hilariously
writing in the caption quote
first they're sweet then they get older
of course all this adorableness comes
after stormy filmed a halloween baking
tutorial with her mama
wow you are such a good helper storm
legit no one was more pumped about it
than storm
are you excited
you are the best type storm yeah or a
hype baby
but frankly the highlight for me was
when stormy called out her mama for
making a mess
what happened mom we made a little mess
oh
we've been so messy so messy
gotta love how kids just tell it like it
is
i love you